this is some breaking Bachelorette news
to blow up your day et has obtained
these photos you're seeing just one of
them behind me and who is it it's Tyler
Cameron the runner-up on this season of
The Bachelorette
and Hannah Brown the series lead why do
they look so comfortable why do they
look so casual well because these photos
were taken in the early morning the two
of them leaving Hannah's place of
residence possibly and apparently after
a hangout throughout the night there in
casual clothes some might call them
pajamas or athleisure coordinating in
black-and-white
looking a little messy a little bed
heady and comfortable with each other
yes this is Tyler Cameron leaving
Bachelorette Hannah Browns house a
possible overnight date round two for
now we'll call this the morning after
whatever it was you can see he's holding
a backpack there just like he did on the
fantasy suites episode of this season of
The Bachelorette the model from Jupiter
Florida spent the night with Hannah
Brown during their fantasy Suites here
they were on the morning after during
the season but notably they both opened
up about the fact that they didn't sleep
together they wanted to use the time to
just get to know each other
Hannah dubbed Tyler the quote most
respectful man she had ever been with
after that night she said that they
would cuddle he would hold her and then
he would pull away she'd never have to
say hey give me some space he just knew
what to do that fantasy suite changed
everything about her feelings for Tyler
she ended up choosing him over Peter
Webber another frontrunner sending Peter
home and leaving Tyler in the top two
with Jed Wyatt ultimately Hannah dumped
Tyler she ended up getting engaged to
singer-songwriter Jed Wyatt here's Hanna
saying goodbye to Tyler in that final
episode just days ago at aired this week
on ABC
so Tyler acknowledged this isn't it he
wished Hanna the best with Jed Wyatt but
the best was oh not at all it was
cracked up to be
it turned out that Hannah brown
discovered along with the rest of the
world that Wyatt had apparently been
lying to her he had gone on the show
while in a relationship with another
woman intending to reunite with that
woman after he made it a significant
time on the show to boost his career in
music so Wyatt said his feelings were
Hannah for Hannah were real but she
didn't buy it and ended up breaking off
their engagement and then on their live
finale who was the last man to come out
Tyler Cameron the two talked and Hannah
asked Tyler for a drink let's take a
listen to that flirtatious invite that
aired Tuesday night your incredible guy
and I'm a single girl
[Applause]
yeah
I don't know I just thought maybe we
could go for a drink and just say it I
would love to just tell me what I'm not
oh well when maybe turned out to be
Thursday night yes here they are again
fans were shook ahthe as Hannah asked
her runner-up out for a drink and the
reaction to these photos well we're sure
that you seeing them are having the same
reaction that we had here in our office
which was oMG for lack of a better word
so Tyler and Hannah if you're just
joining us this is what we're calling
the morning after what might have been
fantasy suites round two
tyler Cameron the model from Jupiter
Florida the runner up on this season of
Hannah Browns unstoppable unforgettable
season 15 of The Bachelorette leaving
Hannah's house with a bag in hand
perhaps an overnight bag now I was with
Hannah brown
I mean I'm no Tyler Cameron but I was
with her the morning after her finale
aired on Wednesday morning in New York
City I interviewed Brown and asked her I
said hey look you asked Tyler out for a
drink but is this just platonic is it
just friends catching up could it be
something more how realistic is a
reconciliation here's what Hannah Brown
had to say Wednesday morning we hang out
and just see where we're at
and you know that's that's friends if
it's more than I'm good with that
because I want to continue to be a part
of his life and I think he wants to be a
part of mine but at what capacity I
don't think we know used yet
but excited to see him and catch up now
I asked Hannah look se you to do go down
that just friends route would you
support Tyler as the next Bachelor a lot
of fans when they saw Hannah say goodbye
to him were immediately crying for Tyler
to become the bachelor 2020 Hannah said
it would be quote hard for her to see
Tyler as the bachelor because she still
has these feelings but that ultimately
she would support his journey towards
happiness because he was such a champion
of hers now after that morning in her
the two both took to Instagram first
here's what I learn to say oh I'm sorry
this is Hannah's Instagram Hannah said
I'm really appreciative that Tyler has
always had my back and supported me
through all my decisions he constantly
encourages me to lean into the strong
woman that I am he's a really good man
and I'm going to be his biggest fan in
whatever makes him the happiest Hannah
also promised him that Instagram that
she and Tyler would get that drink
but that fans would not be a part of it
well maybe we are with these morning
after pictures Tyler also posting a
lengthy look back on his relationship
with Hannah to Instagram and he said as
one chapter closes another one begins
the world is yours girl excited to see
what you do with it looking forward to
that drink now the wording there's
little ambiguous
fans were reading into every word every
sentence and doing some interpreting did
that mean that Tyler was closing the
chapter on he and Hannah's romantic
relationship did he make that drink
sounds like it was just a friendly
catch-up and nothing more well now again
we're seeing the morning-after photos
that you are looking at behind me look
could they have had a fantasy suite much
like they did on the season where they
didn't hook up where they talked all
night long where they worked things out
sure could it have been something much
more also sure but what we know right
now is that Tyler Cameron left Hannah
Browns place of residence early Friday
morning in Los Angeles with a bag in
hand both of them looking a little
disheveled and the ending still remains
to be seen Oh
dare I say is this the most dramatic
season of The Bachelorette ever for more
on what's next for Hannah and Tyler
stick with DT live and also head to ET
online.com where we have new interviews
with the ABC exec who helped figure out
how this crazy season would end and who
is also behind choosing the next
Bachelor
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]